[Music]
and we're gonna go out to oh mandy oh
mandy in nashville what's up
how are you you never heard that one
before have you no never hey listen my
name rhymes with the lunch meat so same
team same team there you go so what's up
uh well i just have a question um
i'll preface by saying i've been married
a while um 20 plus years my husband and
i i mean if i wrote down all the great
things about him
there are many he's amazing he loves his
family well
he loves the lord he's got like
so much going for him so i think over
the years i've just overlooked this one
thing a whole lot and now it's just come
to a point where i'm finally realizing
either i need to see it differently or
he needs to change i'm not sure
but he just has an anger
issue when i say that um he would net we
have two girls in college he would never
yell at me he would never yell at them
and no one would ever you know fear that
he just he's very kind so he's kind of
it's a complex thing he's this kind
gentle bear on the inside but
his office is in our home and when he
gets frustrated
he yells loudly and it's uh to the point
where um
when my girls were little
i would take them out or whatever and um
but now that they're older and gone i
just it's it's a
it's a thing and i don't know if i just
need to like
suck it up and and not worry about him
yelling but it's like i'll give you an
example because i started writing down a
couple of times it's happened so that
if i needed to go and figure out
counseling just to help me know how to
deal with it better or
whatever
but like right before thanksgiving my
girls were home from college we were
cooking in the kitchen and
his office is right by the kitchen he
was frustrated with some circumstances
and just yelling off and on throughout
the day so
we're in there like you know trying to
have fun
and cook for thanksgiving it just like
makes everybody feel on edge and put the
damper
on everything and i also just feel like
i'm apologizing for his behavior too
much uh try to find an excuse for it but
they've grown up with it with him in the
home um and like i said if they needed
something they could walk in his office
and he's there for him but but if if
he's having a bad day you just never
know when it's coming and yelling
so one of my daughters just kind of like
ignores it and acts like it's not
happening the other one she's definitely
been i guess they've both been equally
affected they just deal with it
differently but she just like she can't
stand it and
like me and it just um i don't know it
just it will
squash all of us a little bit and so
i don't know the best way to he knows
and we i mean i'll talk openly to him
and he just feels like he doesn't
know what to do with the stress that
he's under and he doesn't
um
he just doesn't know what to do with it
so then i feel bad like well
am i expecting too much for him but then
i'm like it to me it seems like a temper
tantrum so i don't
but you know so mandy how how
number one thank you for
thank you for your call um this this
affects a lot of folks and so your
willingness to be brave here is gonna be
helpful for folks
um i i asked this with some rare rarity
um how honest can i be
oh a hundred percent are you positive
oh yeah okay yeah i i yes i seek truth
some people say that and then i tell
them they're like ooh i didn't seek that
the type of yelling you're describing is
abuse
and it is trauma
and
the way you preface talking about this
man that you love and that i believe is
a good guy i believe that he loves his
kids i believe he loves you i believe he
works hard to provide
um
is the way
when i've had behind closed doors
discussions with people who are
physically abused who are sexually
abused it always starts with the same
okay let me tell you this first he's
great he's wonderful he's so lovely he's
this and this and this but there's just
one thing
and so i need you to hear me say that
the way you even preface this discussion
is
verbatim how i have these conversations
with folks who have what i what the
world would say is more traditional
um abusive behavior
here's why it's abusive
for your daughter's entire life
they have had to um
regulate
they have been responsible for the
emotions of an adult male in their home
and they have had to learn how to
control the adult emotions in the home
because the adult in the house couldn't
do it himself
and so what they have taken on
themselves is this peacekeeping role
this hey we gotta hide or some kids take
on i don't care i'm gonna flex back
right those are all adaptive trauma
responses
to an unstable emotional environment
that they have felt like they have to
control and how this works downhill
is they're going to find somebody else
to marry
that they feel like they have to
emotionally regulate or they have to
hide themselves completely
even the question and
those two responses are are relatively
common either way and you may notice
that in both of your daughters and
how genetics plays in how personal
experience plays in
it's can often baffle parents like the
same dad is like this kid's doing that
and this one's doing that it tends to be
the same response it just looks
different right or the root response is
different
so
most of us look at people we love and
the word abuse makes us recoil like no
he's not abusive
yeah if you find yourself apologizing
because people in your home are
uncomfortable by behavior if you find
yourself saying hey kids let's just get
out for a minute while dad does what
he's doing
um
so begin to think through that lens and
you'll usually the light comes on and
people go oh my goodness and here's one
that that um is common
you know you've begun to really be
uncertain about
you
you have dealt with this for so long
that you are willing to go get
counseling so that you can learn how to
deal with somebody who's throwing a
grown-up temper tantrum
yeah here's so so when you stop trusting
you
or you start outsourcing your trust to
somebody else that's a cornerstone of
hey i'm not my body recognizes i'm not
safe in this environment
and so
who taught him this somebody showed him
that this is how you respond to things
i
don't i don't exactly know his um i mean
his
i i really his dad is um
definitely short tempered but i don't
see him yelling um
so some dads let me catch so some dads
they don't yell
they become radioactive
i call it the uh silent violence
they are a imp you know if i touch that
bear it will bite my arm off and so
everybody back away or he says that one
sentence and everyone knows this
conversation's officially over
right right and so that is the same
physiological response we have when
someone's yelling their head off
and when i say somebody learned this let
me say that in a better way
um
somebody told your husband that his
thoughts and feelings didn't matter
they need to keep them to himself
somebody told him that i don't care how
you feel you will sit down on your butt
and you will shut your mouth while i
that's
that's the picture he received
and it lodges in and lodges in until it
absolutely explodes
and so when he's yelling who is he
yelling at
well that's just like
he just yells words like he just he's
frustrated with the situation and then
he just feels like the pressure's too
much or you know he's
he's always had the um excuse i could
just i mean you know for a long i mean
i've been working the last few years but
before that he was the primary provider
so just the pressure of all that he
would stay with the
it would just get to him and like he
wanted to but yet
but so he would just something's going
wrong at work uh it's just yelling it's
it's you know it's
into the air yeah it's it's at the
situation so so it's it's into the air
but it's into your nervous system
right it's into the nervous system of
your daughters
right so
um here's what here's here's the lens i
want to paint right and here's the thing
if he showed up here this afternoon was
like you just told my wife i'm abusive i
would say yes i did
yeah okay if he came to see me and i was
a licensed psychologist and he sat down
with me i was a licensed counselor he
sat down with me i would tell him
that the response you are um to things
that aren't going your way
is how my six-year-old responds
and somehow there's a six-year-old still
running the show for him and i don't say
that in a condescending he's acting like
a baby
but there's something there's some
six-year-old in him that's still trying
to protect him
there's some seven or eight or nine year
old that was told some things that he's
still cycling in on okay
so a couple of things
i want you to start considering yelling
as trauma
and i think any sort of trauma response
you're gonna have too one that you've
felt and then there's going to come a
moment as you process this and there's
going to be a a wave of guilt that comes
if it hasn't already which is i'm my
daughter's mom and i should have
protected her right okay all right and
if you sit on that for a minute i bet
it's hard to keep the tears back
yeah
and so
that's where a gift you can provide your
daughters and your husband
is to say i haven't um been true to
myself and i haven't been true to my
daughters for however many years
and daughters
i'm sorry that i didn't get involved
earlier your dad was never gonna hurt
anybody here i was safe and i didn't
know what to do and i thought it was on
me and it's not this isn't okay
and
here is where moving forward you can't
control his behavior only he can
the only thing that you can control is
you
so you need two things
you need a good boundary
and you need choices you're and now
so the boundary is he needs to know in
no uncertain terms
that when yelling happens
you
choose to disconnect
and here's why your choice is important
not he's making you because that's what
yelling does it protects us
it's a seven or eight or nine-year-olds
response to a radius blast everybody get
out of my way i'm overwhelmed my
my ability to respond to this has been
uh
it's overwhelmed
you take the power back
and say when you yell
i am choosing to leave
because when you yell you are choosing
to tell me that you don't want me here
okay
and so i want you to own that boundary
because i don't think your husband wants
to hurt you
no but i also think he has chosen not to
find different ways to deal with him
things not going his way
you see
how far are you taking that because i i
automatically shut down when he does
that and
he knows emotionally i'm just like
checked out went
for a little while
yeah and so instead of um
i i just say when you choose to do that
then you're choosing to not have dinner
with me and i'm gonna go get dinner by
myself
okay or i'm choosing to go have friends
not that i'm moving out unless you feel
unsafe you know i mean that's not saying
at all no no no but i am you you you are
have chosen to violate a boundary
yelling's not okay i don't feel safe in
my home when you do that my body turns
into a raw pile of nerves when you do
that
um and i get sick to my stomach at how
our daughters are gonna meet men who
think this is an okay way to respond to
them to their kids to situations that
they that are out of their control
um and you
are going to choose to leave and here's
what's going to happen
he's going to call your bluff or he's
just not going to think about it or it's
going to come out actually he's been
doing this a long time okay and again
i'm not hating on him at all he's this
is the behavior he's going to have to
change it it's hard it's probably been a
lifelong thing so it will happen and
then you will stick to your guns
and he'll get mad at you for making that
choice
and that's the moment of clarity
when he can choose to not hurt his wife
he can choose to learn different ways to
deal with this
and it's going to be practice for him
and it's going to be hard and there's
going to be a lot of grace involved but
i've set my boundary here
yeah and my guess is um
i've just heard the stories i've talked
to a few folks but the big stories are
when you want to stop yelling you stop
yelling
i will learn something else i will go
for a walk outside i will get up and i
will do 30 push-ups i will
immediately turn my computer off and
spin in my chair tend to i will find a
way yeah
but i'm gonna stop creating an unsafe
space in my home can i ask you this when
you talk to him about this when you've
said i don't feel safe when you yell
what's his response
he's i mean he's very
like he's always been very open to
listening to anything i would have to
say and i can say whatever to him but
he's
like the last
time i talked about he just said he
really just doesn't know what else to do
he's like i don't and he isn't like this
last two weeks they're under
more stress than a normal normal um
couple weeks in his office so it's just
been
um
yeah he just he does it he really
doesn't know
that there's another way if that makes
any sense i don't i don't and and for so
for me i've been like am i
am i expecting too much no absolutely
not absolutely not um where i want to
see
a man in that situation
be real brave be be
the epitome
of concrete strength of of taking his
power back
is recognizing that
without meaning to i'm hurting the three
most important people on planet earth to
me
and
i don't want to hurt them anymore so i
have to be about learning new things
that to me is the single strongest
somebody who can say the words i was
wrong and i need to do something
different and here's what that's going
to look like
wow well that's a counselor well that's
getting with a couple of buddies call
tell him to call my show i i absolutely
don't hate the guy i think he's um
get these under pressure the whole
world's under pressure right now right
right right and every time we're under
pressure we have a choice
we have a choice and what's hard for me
is that you've told him your particular
choice hurts us and his response has
been
i don't know anything else so here we go
and so the ball is in your court to draw
a boundary and to be clear and when i
say clear this isn't a yelling this is
gentle this is quiet this is right right
hey the last two weeks has pushed me
past where i'm comfortable anymore
and the days of me apologizing for you
and your behavior are over now
and
here's here's
here's my new boundary
when you yell
you're choosing i'm choosing to
disconnect and leave
and i'm going to go have dinner by
myself
and if yelling is more important than
being with me so be it feel free to yell
but this i'm not going to be in the
house for anymore i deserve to be safe i
deserve to feel safe i deserve to not
feel like you're going to go off at any
moment
and quite frankly you deserve
a better avenue for dealing with this
the beauty is there's a lot of
opportunities to heal from yelling and
um
i didn't tell you mandy i'm so grateful
for you and for
your willingness to call in the show